foreign
[Applause]
all right
to keep in by bar cross for Hagee throws
it to the front of the net the shot
block by white cloud and then Florida
goes to work and look at Matthew could
jump
position on Zach White Cloud
fortunate bounce Second Chance
opportunity and right off the camera in
the net
saw the ice for Florida foreswick finds
Pettit
ES
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
Potter for Hagee with his fourth career
playoffs overtime goal his second this
season
the Panthers win game three
and on the first shot of overtime
ends up in the back of the net through
the middle of the ice Bennett with a
beautiful pass
[Applause]
and for Hagee just lets a nasty wrister
go right over the glove of Aiden Hill
I don't know if that changed Direction
at all Jonesy but you fire the puck at
the net and the reaction from the
Panthers bench yeah it was good Chuck
that was out front again there's
lebronski as he heads over he hits a big
hug from the veteran Mark Stahl
go back to those saves in that third
period
and then the crossbar by Barbershop
Bob has found his game Chelsea we talked
about it earlier
for Florida they needed to play a lower
scoring